la unión europea anunció que de manera
coordinada este domingo se aplicarían en
todo el bloque las primeras dosis de la
vacuna de las farmacéuticas fisher y
bryant pero varios países se adelantaron
hungría empezó la inoculación del
personal de la salud tan sólo horas
después de haber recibido su primer
cargamento de las dosis a éste se unió a
alemania donde el programa de vacunación
empezó en el estado de sajonia-anhalt en
un hogar de adultos mayores la jornada
se anticipó porque dijeron tener la
infraestructura lista allí la primera en
vacunarse fue una mujer de 101 años
eslovaquia tampoco quiso quedarse atrás
un integrante de la comisión de
pandemias del gobierno fue el primero en
recibir la dosis sin ningún problema ni
siquiera me di cuenta que me estaban
vacunando se siente menos que la
picadura del mosquito que vas tomar o
siempre los cargamentos de facer y
beyoncé que llegaron este sábado a
varios países de la unión europea
la vacuna da esperanza a países como
francia italia y españa los más
golpeados tanto por la primera como por
la nueva ola de contagios estamos
empezando a pasar la página a un año
difícil la vacunación nos ayudará a
recuperar
la vida normal gradualmente la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen dijo que pronto habrá más
vacunas cuando se compruebe su
efectividad y agregó que el bloque ya ha
asegurado las suficientes dosis para
vacunar a sus 450 millones de habitantes